Minister thank you very much for talking
to Sky News can I start by asking you to
give me your assessment of how much of a
crisis Lebanon is in right now well it's
a very serious crisis it's a structural
crisis and we don't have much time to
try to get out of the situation we're
very much aware of the dangers facing
the country and of the necessity to act
very clearly but what a difficult
situation you must be in because you are
trying to implement a plan to turn this
country around you're going to put in
place very painful reforms and at the
same time the people out there are still
calling for wholesale change they don't
they don't recognize your government as
the change that they called for well I
understand the frustration of the people
where even ease we live in that
frustration all of us in different ways
I understand the two gentlemen demands
for change and for major serious change
what we promise and don't by our words
that is to give us some time to start
implementing what you call structural
reforms and take the road of change now
when you talk to real people out on the
street they will tell you that even now
this new government is not being honest
about just how much trouble the country
is in people are unable to withdraw
their own money from the banks they are
losing their jobs I think the the
2018-2019 unemployment rate among young
people was 37 percent it must be almost
double that now we are very much aware
of these very serious problems that the
country is facing in economic financial
crisis would strong you know social
repercussions over time in the immediate
over time and definitely could have
political repercussions in terms of
chaos or whatever it could happen after
what you are saying give us the time
short time to start moving along the
path of serious and the underline
serious comprehensive reforms addressing
different aspects and different sectors
of the Lebanese economy
society life and needs I imagine if I
was if one of the protesters were
sitting here now rather than me they
would say that it's not well as well as
reforms that are needed it actually the
real problem is you not you in
particular but the political class you
are corrupt to the core that is what
I've been told
out there on the streets you accept that
there is a serious problem of corruption
within the organist problem of image of
reception 11 but I'm not defending my
colleague and myself we'll all of us
anyway experts in their own fields we
are not part of the political
establishment traditional political
establishment we're not saying to take
us for granted to presume that we're
going to resolve all problems understand
the frustration for that ends time but
we need a bit of time to move along that
perhaps past experience past promises
created a situation of total in
credibility that people don't trust
anymore the political system don't trust
anymore
I put a certain political establishment
I understand I don't have to agree or
disagree this is not the point here
this is a theoretical discussion but
give us the time necessary to start on
and start judging me when I start
getting on the road on the ground to
start implementing my program which
should be very clear by next week
hopefully will start after having the
vote of confidence hopefully of the
government of the of the Parliament do
you need international help of course we
are of course very much interested and
getting that kind of help that's a
primary interest and objective of the
venes to stabilise their own country it
is the case for any country in the world
but I think the stability the to
stability genuine stability structural
stability of Lebanon also is a regional
interest and the neutral national
interest in margin god forbids if we
fall into a chaotic situation what would
happen we've seen countries doing well
let's talk about that I mean I know it's
a hypothetical but just give us an
assessment of what you think could
happen if your structural reforms don't
work if the international community
doesn't engage and help you out what is
that what is your warning our warning
that it'd be very dangerous
for the future of the country to become
a failed state or a failing state
reaching into that but we have strong
confidence in ourselves from an
extremely realistic perspective from a
very aggressive perspective I repeat
twice to say that we are developing a
very concrete clear realistic roadmap to
move on which I said already it's an
uphill struggle but you need intuition
that you need international health of
course and we were promised
international health by most countries
friends of Lebanon on condition that we
take the road of structural reform but
there is a more than a degree of concern
among some governments around the world
that the government now in place in
Lebanon is a effectively a pro Hezbollah
government Pro here on government and
because of that they are reluctant to to
plow in cash well I could listen to any
kind of accusation respect everybody but
I'm not the government of his bowl of
one particular party or I am NOT the
government of a pro Iran or anybody else
we're not going to go into discussing we
are answering accusations on this and
that matter we are a Lebanese government
the only thing that will guide us is how
can you prove to countries like Britain
who want to help Lebanon but also
consider Hezbollah to be a terrorist
organization linked to Iran is it how
can you prove that Hezbollah is not
running the government here is not
behind your back carriers are doing this
accusation to come and provide the proof
as bola as a Lebanese party represents a
component a political component of the
remaini Society is part of the
government I am responsible at the
Minister of Foreign Affairs to speak and
explain and and and and really
communicate the government position our
government position is already clear
you'll see it tomorrow after tomorrow we
won't have the best of relations we want
to have peaceful settlements of conflict
the best of relations with the Arab
countries with the members of the narco
of support we want first and foremost to
maintain our right to resist and defend
our national territories under
occupation and so on and so to speak the
this is the government policy and
responsible for the government policy
and this is our policy would like to
have
relations with all our friendly
countries Minister thank you for thank
you very much pleasure thanks thank you